the Brazen and brutal attack on the husband
of house Speaker Nancy Pelosi Paul pelusi
underwent surgery to repair a skull fracture
after he was beaten with a hammer inside a
San Francisco home Friday doctors say
they expect the 82 year old to make a
full recovery a suspect is in custody
charged with attempted murder assault
with a deadly weapon burglary and elder abuse
speaker Pelosi was not at home at the time of
the attack Christina rafini is at the Capitol
with the very latest Christina good morning
good morning Michelle law enforcement sources tell
CBS News the Intruder shouted where's Nancy and
plan to detain Paul Pelosi until the speaker
got home now late yesterday police wouldn't
comment on a motive but said the attack was
not random it was targeted and it was wrong
Broadway Across the Scott and Normandy
with the attacker in the house police
say Paul Pelosi was able to make an open
Line 9-1-1 call around 2 A.M on Friday he
was the caller dispatch kind of took it from
there and read between the lines on the Call
Federal sources told CBS News the dispatcher
could hear what sounded like someone being
threatened in the background and since a
high priority alert to law enforcement her
actions in my opinion resulted in both a higher
priority dispatch and a faster police response
I think this was life-saving arriving on scene
police say they saw signs of forced entry
including broken glass our officers observed mitz
Pelosi and the suspect both holding a hammer the
suspect pulled the hammer away from Miss Pelosi
and violently assaulted him with it the suspect
rolled David Wayne depap was immediately
apprehended by police and is facing multiple
felony charges assault with a deadly weapon
elder abuse burglary a CBS News Review of
suspected social media post by David depap shows
him spreading conspiracy theories about Holocaust
denial pedophiles in the government and claims
that Democratic officials run child sex rings
speaker Pelosi who was in Washington DC at
the time of the attack rushed to the San
Francisco hospital where her 82-year-old husband
underwent successful surgery to repair a skull
fracture and serious injuries to his right
arm and hands according to her office but
the break-in raises concerns about the safety
members of Congress and their families enough
is enough is enough campaigning in Philadelphia
last night President Biden condemned the attack
every person of good conscience needs to clearly
and unambiguously stand up against the violence
Senate minority leader Mitch McConnell wrote he
was quote horrified and disgusted by reports of
the incident and Texas Republican Ted Cruz a
longtime critic of Pelosi tweeted we can have
our political differences but violence is always
wrong and unacceptable but yesterday just days
before the midterm election the Department of
Homeland Security issued a new bulletin warning
of a heightened threat towards candidates
running for public office elected officials
and election workers and said some violent
extremists might be motivated by differing
perceptions of issues like government overreach
Firearms regulation and immigration policy issues
that have been front and center in the run-up to
November there's no room for violence anywhere
but we're going to send her back to be with him
in California that's what we're going to go do
now just to clarify it's Capitol Police not
the San Francisco police or the Secret Service
that's responsible for the speaker's security
as well as that for other members of Congress
and law enforcement tells us they do not have the
resources nor is it standard protocol for them to
protect lawmakers families Around the Clock Jeff
just awful details Christina thank you very much